S'ouvrir.
Clint Eastwood a régné
dans le monde du cinéma depuis 60 ans maintenant.
Pourtant cet homme qui est connu dans le monde entier
Reste un mystère.
Il garde farouchement sa vie privée
et attaque ceux
qui parle de ses affaires privées
sans autorisation.
Son enfance, sa vie,
ses relations avec les femmes,
son mode de vie recèle bien des secrets,
que nous nous apprêtons à dévoiler.
La carrière de Clint a commencé au début des années 50.
A 20 ans, lorsqu'il arrive pour la première fois à Hollywood,
le bel acteur a été embauché
à cause de son physique attrayant.
Clint était prêt à prendre des risques
et a saisi toutes les occasions qu'il pouvait
pour devenir une star et plus tard une superstar.
A 40 ans, il est devenu le plus haut
acteur payé dans le monde.
Aujourd'hui, Clint est un monarque
dans le monde du cinéma.
En tant que producteur,
il a amassé une énorme fortune.
En tant que réalisateur, il est salué comme un génie.
Pour comprendre cet homme extraordinaire,
nous allons jeter un oeil à certains
des moments charnières de sa vie.
Nous nous dirigeons vers l'Italie, où Clint Eastwood
voyage a commencé en 1964.
A cette époque, il n'était qu'une starlette
à la télévision américaine
quand le réalisateur Sergio Leone
lui propose un rôle dans un western spaghetti.
Les premières scènes
ont été tournés ici à Cinecittà.
Le film s'appelait
"Une poignée de dollars".
Le héros, "L'homme sans nom"
deviendrait une icône.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes ici
dans ces studios légendaires
avec l'écrivain américain,
Patrick McGilligan,
auteur d'un brillant
et biographie bien documentée.
Conscient de l'effet
cela aurait sur son image,
Clint a intenté des poursuites pour faire interdire cela,
mais en vain.
Clint n'était pas la première idée de Leone.
Leone n'avait vraiment aucune idée de Clint.
Il ne lui a pas parlé.
Son agent pensait
ce serait une bonne idée pour lui.
Clint voulait quitter l'Amérique,
alors il a pris ce travail.
Il est venu en Italie.
Assistant réalisateur de Sergio Leone
m'a dit que Sergio était trop nerveux
même pour aller à l'aéroport,
il devait aller chercher Clint.
Ils l'emmènent dans sa chambre d'hôtel
pour rencontrer Sergio.
Clint a ouvert sa valise
et il avait tout
il allait porter,
le boléro et le serape.
Je ne connais pas le cigarillo
parce que Clint ne fume pas.
Certaines personnes disent que c'était celui de Leone.
Leone n'a pas dit grand-chose publiquement
sur cette première rencontre.
Il a dit que Clint était habillé
de mauvais goût comme la plupart des étudiants américains,
mais il aimait son visage
et il aimait sa façon de marcher.
Il lui a dit, on va faire
un bon western ensemble.
Clint est retourné en Amérique,
personne ne s'attendait à "Pour une poignée de dollars"
être l'un des plus importants
Westerns jamais réalisés.
Un homme assez chanceux
avoir été témoin de cette époque
dans l'histoire du cinéma,
vit toujours à Rome aujourd'hui.
Il est le scénariste acclamé
qui a écrit pour Sergio Leone,
aujourd'hui âgé de 87 ans,
et il s'appelle Luciano Vincenzoni.
J'ai rencontré Clint le lendemain de son arrivée.
Il a lu le scénario pour quelques dollars de plus,
que j'avais écrit pour Sergio Leone.
Il était très heureux de faire des films.
Jusque là,
il était un petit acteur de télévision.
Avec ce film,
il était sur le point de jouer un rôle principal.
Physiquement, il était parfait pour le rôle.
Personne au monde
est capable de manier une arme comme lui.
Il était génial.
Il était si rapide.
J'ai tourné d'autres westerns
avec d'autres acteurs,
mais personne n'était aussi rapide que lui.
Sergio Leone était vraiment dur avec lui.
Il a dit que Clint Eastwood est un acteur
qui a une expression avec son chapeau
et un sans son chapeau.
C'est deux expressions,
ou un avec un cigare et un sans.
Je n'ai jamais jugé Clint en tant qu'acteur.
Je pense que même si aujourd'hui,
après tous les films qu'il a fait,
ce n'est pas un grand acteur,
c'est toujours un grand réalisateur.
Il y a une différence.
Pour le premier film, il a gagné 25 000 $
et un billet d'avion en classe économique.
Pour le deuxième film,
250 000 $
et deux billets d'avion en première classe.
Pour le troisième film,
il a gagné un demi-million de dollars.
Il a été loué
chez une grande star de cinéma internationale.
Aux alentours de 1975,
Je suis allé chez Warner Brothers.
j'ai passé plusieurs heures
parler à Clint seul,
faire une interview avec lui.
Quand tu es seul avec lui,
tu sens le charme,
la facilité, l'intelligence
dont tout le monde parle
que parfois tu
ne voyez pas à l'écran dans les rôles.
Puis, alors que je commençais à travailler sur le livre
et a commencé à parler aux gens dans sa vie,
ils ont commencé à me raconter une histoire
c'était le contraire à bien des égards
du mythe et de la légende de Clint.
Commençons notre voyage
à la recherche de notre légende.
Direction San Francisco,
où il est né.
Pour comprendre le mythe vers l'est,
nous devons traverser un immense continent
avec un territoire inexploré.
Cette Amérique centrale est le terrain de jeu de Clint,
où il a tourné la plupart de ses westerns
et où vivaient ses ancêtres.
Chez les Barthélemy
étaient les arrière-grands-parents de Clint.
Ils tenaient un dépanneur dans le Colorado
où ils vendaient de la nourriture et des outils.
L'arrière-grand-mère de Clint, Sophia,
était parmi les pionniers du nouveau pays.
Ici, elle assiste à une réunion de femmes
au Kansas.
Son mari, Charles Runner,
était à la fois un homme d'affaires,
un acteur et un musicien,
et il possédait un restaurant.
À certains égards,
il était une ancienne version de Clint.
Art et commerce
sont dans les gènes de la famille.
Mesdames et Messieurs,
en préparation de l'atterrissage,
veuillez apporter vos dossiers
et les plateaux en position verticale.
San Francisco est la ville de Clint.
Ses racines sont ici.
C'est un endroit où il revient toujours.
A sa naissance, il était déjà une star.
Le bébé le plus remarquable
à la maternité.
Il est né en 1930
dans un hôpital de San Francisco.
Il pesait 11 livres et six onces.
Les infirmières l'appelaient Samson
car il était le plus gros bébé de la salle.
Quand toutes les mères se sont réunies
apprendre à changer les couches,
il était un modèle de couches quand il était bébé.
Clint a été élevé dans les années 30.
Quelques-uns de ses souvenirs d'enfance
font la navette
la côte californienne avec ses parents
pendant que son père cherche du travail.
Ils ont vécu à Los Angeles pendant quelques années.
Son père pompait de l'essence
pour un couple d'années.
Son père,
au moment où la Seconde Guerre mondiale a éclaté,
avait trouvé un emploi très bien rémunéré
en tant que vendeur dans l'industrie du papier.
Ils ont emménagé dans un très,
quartier bourgeois très confortable
appelé Piémont dans la région de la baie.
De l'autre côté de la baie dans le Piémont,
nous trouvons une des maisons
où vivait la famille de Clint Eastwood
quand Clint avait 12 ans au 107 Hillside Avenue.
Clint a toujours prétendu
avoir passé son enfance
dans les quartiers populaires.
Mais en réalité,
il appartenait à un groupe très privilégié
famille de classe moyenne
et a été scolarisé dans de très bonnes écoles
comme celui-ci,
le lycée technique d'Oakland.
Clint était un prince de son royaume.
Il était l'aîné des enfants.
Il était l'héritier mâle du nom de famille.
C'était ce beau garçon
que sa mère aimait tenir
par-dessus la clôture aux voisins et dire,
n'est-il pas beau mon fils ?
Il a entendu en grandissant à quel point c'était beau
et il était beau.
Je pense que cela a été un aspect important
de son succès,
de sa confiance,
de sa façon de marcher, de son apparence,
la façon dont il interagit avec les gens.
Le look saisissant de l'acteur
trouverait la vedette
dans le rôle culte de l'inspecteur Harry.
Tous les films de la série ont été tournés ici
dans les rues de San Francisco.
Nous avons loué une voiture et remis le volant
au journaliste Jim Van Buskirk,
qui a écrit un livre sur le cinéma
faites dans cette ville photogénique.
Il nous emmène aux endroits clés
où les films de Clint Eastwood ont été tournés.
Quand j'ai écrit le livre, je savais
que beaucoup de films avaient été tournés ici.
Puis, quand j'ai fait la recherche,
il y avait des centaines et des centaines de films
tourné à San Francisco ou tourné
à San Francisco et tourné ailleurs.
Mais je pense que le fait que Clint Eastwood
est né à San Francisco
résonne vraiment dans son film.
Il sait utiliser la ville
à son meilleur effet,
que ce soit le côté granuleux
de San Fransisco
ou le beau côté de San Francisco.
Il sait travailler dans la rue
pour mettre en valeur San Francisco,
et faire de la ville
un personnage de ses films.
Oui, je pense que le fait que Clint Eastwood
est né ici
est vraiment important
aux films qu'il a tournés ici.
J'ai une histoire intéressante
à propos de "Dirty Harry" que je ne connaissais pas.
Le scénario a été écrit à l'origine
pour Franck Sinatra.
Cela se passait à New York.
Frank Sinatra a transmis le film.
Il s'était blessé à la main et le pistolet était trop gros
pour que sa main tienne.
Puis ils ont offert le film à John Wayne.
John Wayne est passé et il a dit,
Je ne prends pas les rejets de Frank Sinatra.
Ils ont demandé à Clint Eastwood,
soit à sa demande
ou alors,
le script a été mis à San Francisco.
C'était le rêve du directeur de la photographie
pour prendre des photos ici.
La nuit tombe sur San Francisco.
Nous terminons la journée en visitant
l'emplacement de code ultime,
L'île d'Alcatraz.
La prison sur laquelle
un autre très réussi
Le film de Clint Eastwood a été tourné,
"Évadez-vous d'Alcatraz".
Le lendemain matin,
nous prenons la route du sud vers Los Angeles
le long de la côte californienne,
qui est parsemé d'endroits
qui ont joué un rôle
dans la vie de Clint Eastwood.
Comme Fort Ord,
l'immense ancienne base militaire
où Clint a été sollicité à 21 ans
aller faire la guerre en Corée.
Clint a essayé d'être sauveteur
et à cause de son apparence,
parce qu'il savait nager,
il a obtenu ce poste de sauveteur.
Certaines personnes disent
c'était sa première formation d'acteur
parce qu'il a traversé
ces leçons en tant que sauveteur
sur la façon de parler aux gens
et comment se déplacer dans certaines situations.
Ce fut pour lui, une sorte d'étape de maturation.
Mais tout s'est passé en partie
pour éviter d'aller en Corée
parce qu'il y avait cette guerre sanglante
continuait et des troupes étaient tuées.
Être sauveteur,
cela vous a empêché d'aller à l'étranger.
Chaque fois qu'il en avait l'occasion,
Clint irait
passer un bon moment au Carmel,
la petite station balnéaire voisine.
Quand Clint était un jeune militaire,
il irait au Carmel pour sortir en boîte.
En Amérique, Carmel est célèbre
pour sa beauté, étant sur la côte.
Lorsqu'il devient riche, il s'installe au Carmel.
Il a une maison là-bas.
Il y ouvre un restaurant.
Le restaurant était célèbre dans son entourage
comme un endroit où Clint pourrait rencontrer des femmes.
Carmel est vraiment probablement
la maison de son cœur.
Carmel n'a guère changé depuis cette époque,
et il reste le fief de Clint.
Il possède un terrain de golf,
plusieurs maisons et un ranch ici.
Quand il est devenu célèbre,
il a même eu un tournoi de tennis
nommé d'après lui.
Quoi de plus,
après avoir fait de la politique,
comme son ami,
Président Ronald Reagan,
il a été élu maire en 1986
et est resté maire pendant deux ans.
Ashley Wright, l'historienne de la ville,
nous ouvre ses archives.
C'est en haut ici
est l'une de ses affiches de campagne.
Ces articles sont intéressants
car ils représentent un large éventail de points de vue
sur ce que les gens pensaient de Clint Eastwood
candidat à la mairie.
Le fait qu'il était une star de cinéma,
des gens ravis.
Il avait été un résident de longue date,
donc je pense que les locaux le connaissaient,
le verrait dans son restaurant.
C'était définitivement excitant.
La participation au vote a été importante.
Il y avait des équipes de nouvelles
De partout dans le monde
pour couvrir cette élection municipale.
Il a l'air très maire.
Il est connu pour ne pas se préparer,
mais juste parler au pied levé.
La raison pour laquelle je voulais tirer
cet album particulier
était de vous montrer notre brochure
sur la candidature de Clint Eastwood à la mairie.
Je suis candidat à la mairie parce qu'il y a
quelques questions vitales importantes
face à notre ville,
Je sais que je peux aider à résoudre ces problèmes.
La presse mondiale inondée au Carmel
pour couvrir l'élection de Clint Eastwood.
Ils l'ont fait avec des gros titres
et j'ai complètement raté ce qui se passait,
qu'il avait cette histoire d'amour
avec une autre femme.
Ma théorie est que Clint voulait
être maire du Carmel
pour qu'il n'ait pas à rentrer chez lui.
C'était un modèle dans sa vie,
qu'il se fatiguerait
de la femme avec qui il vivait
et il faut construire
une vie alternative ailleurs.
On pourra comprendre plus tard
sur ce que le biographe veut dire par là.
Voyager encore une fois
le long de l'océan Pacifique,
nous suivons une des plus belles routes
dans le monde,
celui de l'État entre Carmel et Big Sur.
De ce côté de l'autoroute,
au milieu d'une nature préservée,
est l'endroit où Clint a choisi de localiser l'action
pour le tout premier film qu'il a réalisé,
"Un frisson dans la nuit" en 1971.
Devenir réalisateur
serait un tournant majeur
dans la vie de Clint.
Plus au sud dans ces collines arides
surplombant l'océan,
vit un homme très privé
et un homme important
dans la vie de Clint Eastwood.
Leur collaboration s'est soldée par un procès.
Aujourd'hui, il est à la retraite et vit
dans une grande propriété isolée
caché du monde
et loin du monde du cinéma.
Jeremy Kronsberg a écrit le scénario
et la musique du film
"Dans tous les sens mais en vrac",
qui est sorti en 1978.
Dans son bureau, il garde encore des souvenirs
de ce film original.
C'était un geste risqué
comme c'était la première fois
que Clint a choisi de jouer dans une comédie
alors que le monde l'identifiait encore
avec le personnage de "Dirty Harry".
Dans ce film,
il partageait la tête avec un singe.
Contre toute attente, ce serait
le plus grand succès commercial
de sa carrière.
J'ai essayé de le vendre à toutes sortes de personnes.
Quarante sept personnes
a refusé le script avant de l'avoir.
Le téléphone sonne et ma femme répond
et elle dit, c'est Clint Eastwood.
J'ai dit, oui et elle a dit, Clint Eastwood,
J'ai dit, d'accord.
Clint s'est présenté,
dit-il, j'aime vraiment votre script.
Voudrais-tu venir
et m'en parler ?
Il était très sympathique et je n'ai eu aucun problème
communiquer avec lui.
Il y a Clint et moi,
c'était sur la route du Colorado.
Nous discutons
concernant l'une des scènes.
Je pense que Clint
connaît très bien Clint Eastwood,
mais ce n'est pas un comédien,
il ne comprend pas la comédie.
Dans la comédie, tu prépares une blague
et puis vous le payez à la fin.
Par exemple, il y a une scène
où ils sont à un feu de camp.
Clint déverse son cœur.
Il dit, quand je rencontre une fille,
Je me tourne vers la gélatine royale,
qui est comme Jell-O.
La caméra recule
et vous voyez qu'il parle au singe.
Il verse son cœur au singe,
c'est une autre blague.
J'ai eu des ennuis sur celui-ci
parce que nous sommes dans la limousine,
nous conduisons jusqu'à l'endroit
avec le réalisateur et le caméraman.
Jim Fargo dit, nous allons ouvrir
dans un deux plans de Clint et l'orang-outan.
J'ai dit, tiens-le,
vous ne pouvez pas faire ça.
Parce que si tu t'ouvres sur eux deux,
il n'y a pas de scène.
Vous avez déjà lancé la blague.
Clint était le numéro
une étoile dans le monde à la fois
ou à proximité,
et tout le monde avait peur de lui parler.
Je monterais frapper à sa porte
et dire, Clint, nous devons parler
parce que je voulais juste faire le script
aussi bien que possible.
Je pense qu'il est devenu malheureux.
Quand nous sommes arrivés à Denver, Colorado,
ma ville natale,
Fritz Mânes,
qui était son producteur associé,
il s'est approché de moi et il m'a dit :
Clint ne veut pas de toi
ne plus être sur le plateau, Jeremy.
J'ai réalisé que Clint
n'aimait pas affronter les gens.
Il ne te regardera pas dans les yeux
et te dire qu'il est malheureux.
Il serait sub rosa, irait dans les coulisses
et laisser quelqu'un d'autre faire le sale boulot.
Il n'était pas une personne conflictuelle.
Il joue ces personnages,
mais ce n'est pas qui il est.
Puis j'ai découvert après
ils ont changé toutes les chansons.
Puis j'ai découvert qu'ils avaient invité
tout le monde à la grande fête
vendre la photo au Texas,
et je n'étais pas invité.
Nous avons pu régler
nos différences juridiques
parce que régler signifie
ils vous paient plus d'argent
qu'ils ne veulent,
mais moins qu'ils ne vous doivent.
Le film est devenu un tel succès
que cela m'a beaucoup aidé.
Cela m'a beaucoup appris.
Je n'ai pas de mauvais pressentiment,
Je ne supporte pas les mauvais sentiments.
Je ne peux pas vivre ainsi,
ce n'est pas qui je suis.
Ma vie est trop belle.
Je lui souhaite bonne chance.
Je suis sûr qu'il doit s'occuper de lui-même.
Je n'étais pas payé par le studio.
Nous le déposions.
Quand Clint est entré pour sa déposition,
l'arbitre a dit à Clint,
pourrais-je avoir votre autographe?
J'ai regardé le juge.
J'ai regardé Clint, il m'a regardé
et nous avons commencé à rire.
C'est la dernière fois que je l'ai vu.
Nous sommes en route pour Los Angeles
sur la célèbre route américaine 101
à travers de vastes plaines agricoles.
Quand il était petit,
La famille de Clint a parcouru ces autoroutes
pendant la Grande Dépression des années 30,
son père cherche du travail
partout en Californie.
Il n'y a pratiquement pas de photos
des parents de Clint ou de lui enfant
comme il n'a rien à faire
avec cette période de sa vie
enfermé dans ses biens privés.
En 1982 cependant, il réalise un film
à cette époque de sa vie, "Honkytonk Man".
C'est peut-être
cette expérience d'enfance nomade
qui a conduit Eastwood à choisir des rôles
dans lequel il joue le déraciné,
les cow-boys errant dans la terre aride.
Nous sommes sur notre approche finale
à Los Angeles.
Étendues de banlieue sans fin
où missionnaires, colons,
chercheurs d'or,
migrants et cohortes ambitieuses
est venu s'installer
à la recherche de la célébrité hollywoodienne.
Clint Eastwood
était l'un de ces espoirs anonymes
alors qu'il n'avait que 20 ans.
L'usine à rêves s'est brisée
les rêves de beaucoup de jeunes acteurs,
mais il a aussi mis certains
des plus grandes stars
en orbite pour l'éternité.
Après notre première journée sur le sol californien,
nous partons maintenant dans la nuit
dans la cité des anges,
finir sur Sunset Boulevard,
où obtenir
dans le domaine du divertissement,
vous devez vous montrer ici.
La renommée de Clint Eastwood
continue à ce jour.
Son dernier film
qui vient de sortir
envahit les espaces publicitaires.
Depuis les années 1960, Clint Eastwood filme
ont régné dans le royaume cinématographique.
Clint est peut-être désormais une figure emblématique,
mais son parcours pour y arriver
était toute une histoire.
Tout a commencé ici
après son service militaire.
Clint est venu tenter sa chance
ici à Hollywood,
et a été remarqué par un réalisateur gay
appelé Arthur Lubin,
qui faisait des films
pour Universal Studios.
Il a été frappé par le beau visage de Clint,
sa stature de six pieds quatre pouces
et son corps athlétique.
Il y a un mystère sur la façon dont Clint
est arrivé à Hollywood et a commencé à jouer.
Arthur Lubin est allé le voir
où il travaillait dans une station-service
le mettre sous contrat,
l'a amené à Universal
rejoindre leur école de jeunes talents.
Sur cette photo du début des années 50,
nous voyons Clint assister à un cours
où Marlon Brando
était venu rencontrer les élèves.
Ils ont dû faire des tests d'écran de lui
pour voir ce qu'il était capable de faire.
Le premier test d'écran
est très dramatique et très intense.
Clint ne s'est vraiment pas débrouillé.
Il n'avait aucune formation.
Un des assistants d'Arthur Lubin
eu une autre idée.
Mettons-le dans un maillot de bain étriqué,
presque un suspensoir.
Filmons-le
et juste lui poser quelques questions.
Arthur Lubin le considérait comme un bœuf.
C'est une partie amusante de sa personnalité
et je le commente dans mon livre,
qu'il aime
se déshabiller dans les films.
Il est souvent dans la baignoire
ou il a sa chemise.
Ce n'est pas vrai pour toutes les stars.
surtout des stars masculines
en particulier.
Cette première idée dont je suis sûr
il était au courant,
était implanté dans sa psychologie,
qu'il a l'air si bien
devant la caméra avec sa chemise
mène à bien
pour tout le reste de sa carrière.
Même maintenant, alors qu'il est dans les années 80,
et certainement quand il avait 70ans,
il jouait des personnages parfois
qui pouvait à peine sortir du lit.
Ils sont vieux, il grince,
mais dans la scène importante
où le méchant court,
il court aussi vite qu'eux.
Il montre toujours
lui-même hors physiquement.
C'était une partie très importante
de sa psychologie
car c'est pour cela qu'il a été embauché.
Arthur Lubin me l'a dit,
il a dit qu'il était si beau.
Il était juste un bœuf de choix.
Clint avait d'autres ambitions,
il voulait apprendre à jouer.
Sous contrat avec Universal,
il a pris des cours avec un entraîneur de boxe.
Il décroche des petits rôles dans des films B
comme "François dans la marine"
et "La première vendeuse itinérante".
Heureusement,
durant ces premières années difficiles,
Clint a trouvé une petite amie sérieuse
qui l'ont soutenu financièrement.
Quand Clint était à Fort Ord,
il voyait plusieurs femmes.
Il a rencontré sa future femme, Maggie,
qui était une étudiante,
et que Clint n'était jamais allé à l'université.
Mais ils ont vraiment sympathisé immédiatement.
Quand ils ont déménagé à Los Angeles,
elle avait un meilleur travail,
elle a été mannequin de maillot de bain pendant un certain temps.
Ils ont surpris tout le monde
en se mariant si vite.
Ils se sont mariés à Noël
de 1953 à Pasadena.
Si vous voyez des photos d'eux
depuis ce moment,
ils ressemblent à des photos de deux modèles.
Très belle, très jeune.
Ils regardent sur les photos
être très amoureux.
Les jeunes mariés se sont installés
dans une résidence
situé au coeur
de la vallée de San Francisco,
non loin des studios Universal.
C'est là que beaucoup de jeunes
et des acteurs ambitieux vivaient.
Beaucoup de ces personnes
vivait à la Villa Sands,
qui était un motel californien classique
avec une immense piscine.
Il y avait beaucoup de fête.
C'étaient vraiment des jeunes
qui cherchaient tous un avenir en or.
Foule assez droite,
Je veux dire, une foule de bière.
Clint aimait les femmes.
Après leur déménagement à Villa Sands,
Maggie a été confrontée
avec une énorme compétition féminine.
Toutes sortes de gens y vivaient.
Des gens comme Anita Ekberg
viendrait faire une séance photo
dans son maillot de bain bikini.
Une actrice qui vivait là-bas,
Lili Kardell sortait avec James Dean.
C'est marrant parce que Clint
ressemblait un peu à James Dean,
sauf qu'il est incroyablement grand.
Dean, bien sûr, était déjà une légende.
Il est venu une fois
pour récupérer Lili Kardell.
Clint est passé par là.
Dean est langoureusement sur le canapé
et dit bonjour.
Clint dit, bon sang,
garçon, lève-toi et serre la main
quand tu veux dire bonjour,
il l'a vraiment surpris.
Puis quand Dean s'est levé,
Clint lui aurait donné un de ceux-là
sourires lents à moitié moqueurs.
Ses amis de l'époque m'ont dit
il avait beaucoup de copines
qu'il se vanterait d'eux en privé
quand Maggie n'était pas là.
Parfois, ils étaient relativement
des gens célèbres comme Jayne Mansfield.
Un ami m'a dit est venu à une fête
à la Villa Sands dans une tenue remarquable.
Puis elle et Clint
a disparu pendant un certain temps.
Après,
Clint s'est vanté que lui et Jayne
avait passé un bon moment en secret
dans une autre partie du motel.
A cette époque, c'était Maggie
qui a fait de l'argent
dans la maison Eastwood.
Malgré une ambiance agréable et apparemment insouciante
la vie sous le soleil de Californie,
Clint avait du mal.
Universal n'a pas renouvelé son contrat.
Il a pris tous les petits rôles mineurs
qui est venu son chemin.
Le voici en 1957 dans la série télévisée
"Histoire de West Point".
C'était à cette époque
qu'il a décidé d'arrêter de jouer.
Finalement, il a persévéré
et suivi un cours de théâtre
avec un entraîneur nommé Jack Kosslyn,
qui deviendra son mentor.
Sa chance allait tourner.
En privé, les gens
avait commencé à voir son potentiel.
Il s'était très bien débrouillé en couple
de petits petits rôles dans des cours de théâtre.
Parfois, il était très impressionnant.
Parfois, il improvise
et il époustouflait tout le monde dans la pièce.
En privé, les gens ont vu ça,
mais publiquement,
il n'avait pas encore commencé à émerger.
Il pensait vraiment à arrêter
quand cette émission de télévision est arrivée
à propos d'un transport de bétail, "Rawhide".
Il a obtenu l'un des deux rôles principaux.
En fait, ce spectacle a été presque immédiatement
un des dix meilleurs succès en Amérique.
Il a joué un rôle
qui au départ était très similaire
à un gars tranquille qui a eu des moments
de quand tu as vraiment besoin de lui,
montre son courage.
Beaucoup de charme et un plaisir pour les dames.
Il a connu un énorme succès
à la suite de "Rawhide".
La carrière de Clint a décollé.
Par dessus tout,
cela a commencé à lui rapporter très bien sa vie.
Cela lui a permis d'investir
dans une maison de Beverly Glen.
Cette maison que Clint et Maggie
possédé à l'époque existe toujours,
caché dans un petit chemin
dans les collines surplombant la vallée.
C'était un moment heureux pour Clint
alors qu'il appréciait son nouveau statut de célébrité.
Il a fait la promotion de "Rawhide"
ici à Las Vegas avec une starlette.
Il avait une collection de jolies filles
comme la championne de natation Anita Lust.
Maggie n'était pas au courant
des escapades de son mari
ou fait semblant de ne pas savoir.
J'ai parlé à certaines des copines de Clint
au début des années 1960
quand je faisais des recherches pour mon livre.
La plupart d'entre eux l'aimaient encore
ou l'aimaient.
J'ai trouvé qu'il était
un fêtard merveilleux et drôle.
Kitty Jones en était une
et son amie Jill Banner.
C'étaient des fêtardes célèbres à Hollywood.
Certaines personnes de ce groupe
sont des gens avec qui ils ont fait la fête.
Des gens comme Elvis Presley.
Marlon Brando, qui s'amusaient
Hollywood à l'époque.
Il menait vraiment une double vie
à ce moment-là.
Il menait une vie de couple heureux
vedette de la télévision américaine,
pendant ce temps-là
il vivait vraiment une vie sauvage
Dans les coulisses
avec différentes copines.
L'une était une cascadeuse
qui avait de petits rôles sur "Rawhide".
Clint a eu une histoire d'amour très sérieuse.
Elle s'appelait Roxanne Tunis.
Tout le monde à "Rawhide"
savaient qu'ils avaient une relation.
Certaines personnes savaient qu'elles avaient un enfant.
Clint rentrerait chez lui avec Roxanne
et promenez le bébé autour du bloc.
Ensuite, il lui dirait au revoir.
Il rentrerait chez Maggie
et avoir quelque chose à manger.
Alors sors et fais la fête toute la nuit
avec ses amis masculins.
La vie de Clint était compliquée.
Il a eu un enfant avec sa maîtresse.
Puis un autre enfant
plusieurs années plus tard avec sa femme, Maggie.
Ceci est une photo de Clint
et la fille de Roxanne,
Kimber Tunis, née en 1964.
La presse ne révélerait pas son existence
jusqu'à 20 ans plus tard.
"Rawhide" était un moment clé dans le bâtiment
de l'image légendaire de Clint.
La façon dont il a structuré son contrat,
il aurait pu mettre cet argent de côté
et n'a plus jamais fonctionné.
Au lieu de cela, ce qui s'est passé
était Sergio Leone est venu.
Il cherchait un profil bas
acteur américain
jouer profil bas
Western spaghetti.
Clint avait hâte de passer à autre chose
vers un royaume supérieur.
Il voulait faire quelque chose
au-delà de "Rawhide", il a donc pris le poste.
C'est en prenant ce risque majeur
que Clint a saisi l'opportunité
devenir une star internationale.
À partir de ce moment,
les choses ont commencé à se mettre en place.
Il a enchaîné les succès,
principalement avec des rôles de cow-boy.
Ici, l'acteur pose
avec le réalisateur Ted Post
sur le tournage de "Hang 'Em High".
Ici, avec Roxanne Tunis,
qui était venu lui rendre visite sur le plateau.
Ici, il est photographié sur le plateau
du film "The Beguiled",
avec une autre de ses copines de longue date,
Jo Ann Harris.
Clint assumerait également le rôle
d'un flic dans des films comme "Dirty Harry",
un geste qui sécuriserait
son succès futur fulgurant.
Sur le plateau, il s'est associé
avec l'un des réalisateurs les plus brillants
des années 70, Don Siegel,
qui lui a appris le métier.
Ce triomphe lui a valu l'accès
aux plus hautes sphères d'Hollywood.
Sur cette photo historique, Clint Eastwood
pose avec Barbra Streisand,
Rock Hudson, John Wayne
et Yves Montand entre autres.
La trajectoire montante de Clint
fait de lui l'un des plus puissants
et les hommes les plus riches d'Hollywood.
Certainement l'un des derniers
géants de l'écran de l'âge d'or,
avec Marlon Brando,
James Dean ou Marilyn Monroe.
Ayant atteint ces sommets,
Clint est resté marié à Maggie.
Ceci est une photo d'eux ensemble
à son 40e anniversaire
avec leur premier enfant, Kyle,
qui venait d'avoir deux ans.
Ils auraient même
un deuxième enfant ensemble,
une fille nommée Alison, née en 1972.
Ce que Maggie ne savait pas
était que Clint avait beaucoup
affaires et relations extraconjugales,
certains étant si stables,
on pourrait les appeler polygamie.
À Hollywood,
nous avons rendez-vous avec Sondra Locke,
une actrice qui a commencé
vivant avec Clint en 1975.
Bien qu'il soit toujours marié à Maggie.
Leur histoire d'amour a duré près de 15 ans
et s'est terminé par une séparation épuisante
avec deux essais de haut niveau.
Elle en veut toujours à son ex,
c'est pourquoi
elle accepte de nous parler aujourd'hui.
Clint a dit tant de mauvaises choses sur moi
aux médias depuis notre séparation.
Il a tellement plus d'accès
et le pouvoir de le faire.
Il a dit des choses blessantes
à mon caractère et à moi professionnellement.
C'est ça,
ce n'est pas vraiment pour attaquer à nouveau Clint
ou le combattre à nouveau,
ou dire certainement rien de faux à son sujet.
C'est pour parler de ce qui m'est arrivé
et de me présenter.
C'est ma raison.
Sondra a écrit un livre où elle parle
de son expérience avec Clint.
Quand elle a osé le défier
devant un tribunal,
il l'a bannie du monde du cinéma.
Il est certainement une icône.
Il était probablement un
des dernières grandes stars du cinéma glamour.
Au-delà, sur le plan personnel,
Je n'ai rien de bon à dire.
Nous roulons jusqu'à sa maison
caché sur une colline.
Elle nous raconte sa première rencontre
avec Clint en 1975
sur le tournage du film,
"Le Hors-la-loi Josey Wales".
Nous tournions à Lake Powell, en Arizona,
c'était vraiment beau là-bas.
Oh mon Dieu,
les lacs et le ciel.
C'était juste un endroit magnifique
et très romantique.
C'était juste une attraction immédiate
entre nous deux.
Il est venu à cheval
dans sa tenue complète Outlaw Josey Wales.
Il avait une barbe,
dont vous vous souvenez probablement dans ce film.
C'était juste un peu magique.
C'était un moment magique,
il était ce cow-boy emblématique sur le cheval.
Je pense que nous étions tous les deux très amoureux
pendant très longtemps.
Nous avons été très heureux pendant très longtemps.
Il m'a demandé de l'appeler papa.
Il était comme une grosse épaule.
Je l'ai perçu comme un rocher,
quelqu'un sur qui je pourrais toujours compter.
Il était plus âgé de plusieurs années.
La dynamique que nous avions
pendant une grande partie de ces années ensemble,
peut-être pourquoi cela a si bien fonctionné,
parce que j'étais l'enfant
et il était le père.
Maggie, de plus en plus absente
de la vie de son mari,
s'installe au Carmel avec ses enfants.
Lorsque Clint a rencontré Sondra, il a emménagé dans
la maison de Beverly Glen avec elle
où il avait vécu avec Maggie
à l'époque de "Rawhide".
je ne me sentais pas vraiment à l'aise
là à cause de ça.
Parce que c'était encore exactement comme c'était
quand lui et Maggie vivaient dans cette maison.
je lui ai dit
que je voudrais une autre maison.
J'ai trouvé cette maison sur Stradella Road.
C'était une belle maison espagnole de Monterey.
Dans la vaste résidence privée de Bel Air
où résident stars et millionnaires,
nous trouvons la maison Stradella Road.
Approche de la destination sur la droite.
Il est difficile d'imaginer ce qui s'est passé
derrière ces portes.
Sondra Locke nous montre une vidéo amateur
elle avait fait à l'époque
quand elle y habitait
avec Clint au début des années 80.
Le balcon était juste droit
des petits bâtons, c'est tout.
J'ai mis tous les virages.
Si tous les messages avaient tourné,
copie exacte de ces autres.
Les petits poteaux, j'ai fait ça.
Ce n'était qu'un mur ici.
Il y avait un mur juste ici.
C'étaient comme des poteaux de plâtre
qui vient de monter à ce faisceau ici.
Ce que j'ai fait était
J'ai détruit tout le mur.
j'ai mis différentes pièces
de lits différents ensemble.
J'ai fait faire ça.
Une entreprise au Texas l'a fait pour moi.
J'ai tout fait moi-même.
J'ai trouvé chaque morceau de tissu,
chaque meuble.
j'étais amoureux
avec chaque centimètre de tout l'endroit.
Que s'est-il passé qui a poussé Clint
être candidat à la mairie de Carmel
était qu'il possédait ce restaurant,
l'auberge Hog's Breath.
Il voulait construire un immeuble
à côté, je pense.
Il a dépassé la hauteur requise
que la ville permettrait.
Ils lui ont refusé son intention de le faire.
Je me souviens qu'il m'a dit,
Je vais faire ce que je veux faire.
Si je dois diriger la ville, je transporterai.
Puis il a dit, je vais me présenter à la mairie.
Il s'est présenté à la mairie, il a été élu.
Je crois qu'il a construit son immeuble
juste comme il le voulait.
J'ai écrit ça dans mon livre
juste une anecdote
alors que nous volions vers Carmel
de Los Angeles, probablement.
Il a dit, regarde en bas, voilà Carmel,
voilà mon royaume.
En fait, une fois que nous étions à Washington, DC,
quand Reagan était président.
Nous étions dans une limousine, c'était le soir.
Nous roulions autour de D.C.
et les bâtiments étaient tous éclairés.
C'était beau.
Il a dit, regarde, ma chérie, parce que ma chérie
est l'une des choses qu'il m'a appelé.
Tout cela pourrait être à nous.
J'ai pensé, oh, non, je ne pense pas,
Je ne peux pas imaginer que cela se produise.
Je ne m'imagine certainement pas
dans ce scénario.
Nous étions amoureux,
c'était super et tout ça.
J'ai ressenti ce besoin de faire quelque chose
tout seul à ce moment-là.
La relation a commencé à changer
quand j'ai commencé à réaliser.
Je voulais diriger,
J'ai exprimé mon intérêt pour la réalisation.
J'ai trouvé un script, "Ratboy".
Il sentait qu'il perdait le contrôle de moi.
Il y avait quelque chose de menaçant
à propos de mes débuts à la réalisation,
s'éloigner de ça
papa petite fille comédienne, réalisatrice cocoon
que nous avions vécu.
Il est juste devenu de plus en plus distant
en même temps.
Il disparaîtrait soudainement
et ne pas me dire qu'il quittait la ville.
Puis la prochaine chose que je savais,
Je suis rentré et il était à Carmel.
Ce serait la fin de leur histoire d'amour.
Elle était prête à apprendre à la dure,
qu'il y a un autre côté
à Clint Eastwood.
Il a envoyé une lettre de son avocat
me disant de ne pas rentrer à la maison,
que les serrures
avait été changé sur la maison.
Mes vêtements étaient entreposés
et que je pourrais les ramasser.
J'ai eu l'audace quand il m'a enfermé
sortir de la maison pour aller chercher un avocat.
Je voulais récupérer ma maison.
Sondra n'a jamais récupéré sa maison,
malgré les procès contre Clint,
au cours de laquelle
elle a dû faire face à des avocats féroces.
Malheureusement,
ce n'est pas le pire.
j'avais reçu un coup de téléphone
d'un journaliste
qui a écrit pour les tabloïds.
Il a dit, connaissez-vous une maison
dans telle ou telle rue du Carmel
c'est dans le nom
du directeur commercial de Clint?
J'ai dit non,
Je n'en savais rien.
Nous avions une maison
sur une autre adresse à Carmel.
Il a dit, Clint a une femme là-bas
et il a deux enfants avec elle.
Quand j'ai eu ça, j'ai juste pensé,
oh mon Dieu,
soit il est passé du blanc au noir
ou j'ai vécu avec quelqu'un
Je ne savais même pas.
Ayant été si amèrement déçu
par ce géant du showbiz,
Sondra ressent toujours le besoin
dire sa vérité.
Ce n'est qu'après la tombée de la nuit
qu'elle accepte de nous faire visiter
dans sa maison actuelle,
qui est plein de restes,
histoire et souvenirs personnels.
C'est un refuge très intime
où elle vit seule,
loin du monde du showbiz.
C'est ma maison maintenant,
c'est le genre de décor.
J'ai fait beaucoup de choses ici
semblable à ce que j'avais fait
dans la maison Stradella.
Je suis très heureux
de l'avoir recréé pour moi-même.
Merci d'être venu.
Vous pouvez voir un peu d'Hollywood
au loin.
Hollywood a brillé.
Dans les années 90,
après avoir quitté Sondra Locke,
Clint continuerait
pour montrer à quel point il était vraiment puissant.
Sa vie serait pavée de succès
et les honneurs
tandis que sa maîtresse,
une hôtesse de l'air nommée Jacqueline Reeves,
venait de donner naissance à deux des
enfants illégitimes au Carmel.
Il a rencontré l'actrice Frances Fisher,
avec qui il a emménagé
et avec qui il a aussi eu un enfant.
Il a donné un rôle à Frances
dans le film "Impardonné".
En 1993, Clint Eastwood a reçu
la récompense ultime pour ce film,
l'Oscar du meilleur réalisateur et du meilleur film.
Seulement une victoire partielle, cependant,
que ses pairs ne lui ont pas accordé
l'Oscar du meilleur acteur.
Un Oscar qu'il ne gagnerait jamais.
Cependant, sa vie privée était comparable
à un feuilleton
avec beaucoup de rebondissements et beaucoup de drame.
En 1993, alors qu'il était
promouvoir "Impardonné",
il a rencontré un jeune journaliste de la télévision
nommée Dina Ruiz.
Il a été épris d'elle,
et il commença à la voir secrètement,
même s'il était encore théoriquement
avec Frances Fisher.
Quand Clint est allé aux Oscars
pour "Impardonné",
Frances Fisher était enceinte,
mais il ne voulait pas qu'elle le dise à personne.
Frances Fisher
a été très vite écarté.
Clint a commencé à être vu
de plus en plus avec Dina Ruiz.
Il s'est marié en trois ans.
Il s'est marié en 1996 à Las Vegas.
Ils sont restés heureux mariés,
du moins à notre connaissance, à ce jour.
Nous ne savons pas combien d'enfants
Clint a eu avec combien de femmes.
Nous ne savons pas exactement.
L'un était quand il était encore
au lycée, je raconte cette histoire.
Et puis il y a Kimber Tunis,
la fille qu'il a eue avec Roxanne Tunis.
Puis il y a les deux enfants
qu'il a avec Maggie, sa première femme.
qu'il a eu avec Jacqueline Reeves
lorsqu'il était maire du Carmel.
Ensuite, il y a la fille de Frances Fisher.
Puis il y a le seul enfant
qu'il a avec Dina Ruiz.
J'ai entendu parler d'autres possibilités
quand je faisais mon livre.
Depuis son mariage avec Dina Ruiz
et leurs enfants ensemble,
je ne pense pas qu'il ait été
avec n'importe quelle autre femme
qui a été rapporté dans la presse à ce jour.
Avec Dina Ruiz,
La carrière de Clint est entrée dans son apogée.
Il obtient une véritable reconnaissance professionnelle.
De nombreux prix et distinctions
De partout dans le monde
lui ont été accordés.
Son travail a été acclamé par la critique.
L'un d'eux était
les "Ponts du comté de Madison" en 1995.
Un autre était "Million Dollar Baby" en 2004
et "Gran Torino" en 2008.
Dans une carrière hollywoodienne
qui dure depuis près de 60 ans,
Clint a cessé de jouer des petits rôles
devenir une superstar.